Asha's with us in illinois i ash welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave um I
just found out from my roommate that I
am getting my wages garnished and I was
wondering is there any way to stop a
garnishment without bankruptcy because I
don't want to go down that route how did
your roommate know your wages were being
garnished uh he called me and told me I
had a letter in the mail because I'm an
over-the-road truck driver and it said
wait garnishment on it I had him open it
and read it to me immediately does it
threaten it or it says it's occurring on
a certain date um it says that the order
was granted on July 19th and it's about
to start
okay and it alright because here's the
thing a lot of collectors will threaten
wage garnishment in a way that sounds
like it is definitely occurring and
they're lying they haven't done anything
yet so I'm a little bit wondering if
that's happening or if they have
actually sued you one and are now
executing on the judgment with an actual
wage garnishment they could what kind of
debt is this um well I I'm actually
looking at the court order right now I
just downloaded it on my tablet okay and
it's from a training program that I in
that I attended back in 2002 okay and
how much do you owe them um the actual
judgment amount is eleven thousand but
they are collecting twenty two thousand
okay they can't collect more than the
judgment amount so there's something
wrong with that but I mean the judgment
if the judge gave them under the ability
to collect 22,000 that's the judgment
but uh so anyway how was the original
dad eleven thousand
uh the original cost of the training I
believe was about 5,000 which I was
paying on but due to my own stupid
decisions during a time of crisis for me
I ended up in prison for a couple of
years oh my goodness and I just got how
long he's gonna hell about how I got out
in 2015
okay but I started going back down the
same route that I was on before I went
to prison and then which I'm not gonna
lie it involved a lot of drugs and
alcohol I woke up one day and I said I'm
tired of this life and I got my CDL
started driving and I've been clean and
sober for a little over a year now
mm-hmm good for you congratulations
well done okay so we're turning things
around this is in the past but we still
got to clean it up and part of being
becoming sober is dealing with the
damage from the past agreed yes very
much so
okay so proud of you man congratulations
for turning your life around so what do
you make now um it varies like last week
I'm only brought home $400 because I
didn't get very many miles a week before
but it all depends on how many miles I
get every week what do you usually get
by on average about 800 a week okay all
right so you're making about 45 50
thousand a year right I'm on pace to
make about 45 this year yeah good okay
and you've been dry for a year do you
have any other debts that you're paying
on um actually I've been pulling
everything off of Credit Karma getting
in touch with all
the creditors and trying to get them to
let means make small payments and stuff
like that how many things are you agent
how many things are you making payments
on now right now I've got one two three
four that I'm making payments to right
now okay
not including the garnishment gotcha
because here's what's running through my
mind mathematically if we could if you
could figure out a way to just live on
nothing and scrape money together scrape
money together scrape money together and
you were to offer these people five
thousand dollars as a settlement on this
debt cash on the Barrelhead they'll
probably take it okay and because they
probably think they're not going to get
all their money after this after this
amount of time and so with it being a
training from a school that you did
attend this probably is a wage
garnishment it is the type of thing that
would sue and would go all the way to
garnishment so that's probably a valid
document you probably are getting
garnished the only way to stop that is
to pay them some amount that they agree
to in cash so it might be that you get
garnished for one month right and during
that month again during that month you
just work like a thousand hours and do
anything you can do whatever you can do
you sell everything don't pay anybody
else for that month on all the other old
bad debts and scraped together like five
grand and offer him five grand I don't
know if you could pull that off in one
month or not it may take two months but
something like that is probably would
settle it with them and make them go
away they're not going to just allow you
to start making payments they're going
to take it out your check they got you
now all right they got you where they
want you now you're not in a strong
position anymore so bankruptcy does not
solve it unless you filed a chapter
seven bankruptcy which dismisses all
unsecured debt and starts fresh that's
the clean slate bankruptcy how much
other debt have you got total a total
got it figured out to be about 28,000
including this or on top of this
including this oh wow so you don't have
much other this whole thing I think
about it then yeah I mean it's 1,200
here thousand here yeah
it's not much whatsoever what sectors
will solve these guys you can beat those
other guys off pretty quick they're
mosquitoes yeah because I mean before I
went through my time of crisis and ended
up in prison I used to listen to you
every day and I started working the baby
steps I was on baby step two and then I
had a like I said I had a personal
crisis which ended up with me in prison
yeah and how old are you I am 40 years
old good well I'm proud of you getting
sober and staying sober for a year well
done proud of you being responsible and
addressing these issues that's the kind
of thing you need to do which helps your
sobriety it also helps your career helps
your future everything you're doing is
smart and wise it's a better path that
you're on
very well done sir I want you to go
through Financial Peace University it's
all online now which works well for a
truck driver I want you to go through as
my guest I'm gonna give it to you and be
part of your newfound sobriety okay okay
all right you hold on Madison will pick
up and we're get you signed up for
Financial Peace University well done sir
well done open phones at Triple Eight 8
to 5 5 2 to 5 you jump in we'll talk
about your life and your money brave
young man they're brave to fight through
that I've been through some obvious
stuff I've done a lot of stupid stuff in
my life have you
have you see financial problems are
almost never the problem Larry Burkett
used to say they're the symptom and when
I had financial problems over the
symptom of my stupidity what about you
now that's what Ash's got he went
through a stupid period and now he's got
the full crop of stupid coming in and
he's having to clean it up the good news
is you don't have to do it again you can
make choices for the rest of your life
that don't leave you in that situation
me too this is the Dave Ramsey show